it's not what i want or you want it's
what the institutions want
institutions that are just stepping in
or considering getting involved in
allocating to crypto
want one thing bitcoin we're not gonna
print
two trillion dollars worth of paper that
currency is
going to be digital it's just in what
form
[Music]
you've historically been a strong critic
and a strong advocate
for bitcoin so well when things change i
change
i mean it's i listen i get this thrown
in my face every time i talk about
bitcoin but here are the facts
yes i was a critic for a while but i got
into bitcoin in 2017
my first purchase i got into a lot of
issues with regulators
they were not on board for conversations
about bitcoin at that time
everything's changed since then you've
got regulators in switzerland canada new
zealand
you know even here loosening up their
discussions about
digital and bitcoin specifically and as
a result you know
i've sort of come out and said look i've
got a three percent allocation
in bitcoin and uh i intend to hold at
his property
all right so why are you involved in
bitcoin you said you got involved in
2017
what was it that piqued your interest i
mean obviously you're wildly successful
in the legacy finance space in the world
of vc investing
what was it about bitcoin that caught
your eye back then
why are you in the space i never looked
at it as a currency
i looked at it and i'll give you an
analogy
i'm a huge watch collector i collect
very rare pieces
from all around the world vintage new
ones etc
but what matters in the watch business
is rarity
exclusivity uniqueness and when you're
able to buy let's say
a watch manufacturer like fp journal
makes 10 pieces and you're one of the
owners of those 10
what do you think happens to the price
it goes to the moon as they like to say
and that's exactly what happens
there's no difference with bitcoin
clearly at the end of the day you have
to make a decision i look at it this way
if you're like me and you're allocating
assets and you have a portfolio
prior to bitcoin i had a five percent
waiting in gold i've had that for
decades
now the way i look at bitcoin is okay
binary decision do i want to own it or
not yes no if it's yes
what percentage allocation do i use
because once i've made the decision to
own it i've got to decide what
percentage of the portfolio is and for
me right now that's three percent
now i do not consider it a currency
that's my personal opinion others might
but for me
it's a property it's like an fp journal
watch
i'm going to buy it i'm never going to
sell it i'm not going to trade it i'm
going to own it and i anticipate it will
appreciate over time
and probably beat the s p 500 index
just like my fp journal does when you
come you say you don't think it's a
currency so you're kind of coming at it
from more of a
scarcity first kind of angle right i
think it may it may end up being a good
hedge against inflation we don't know
yet
obviously the volatility is problematic
for many institutional investors
um i have taken the decision to say look
i'm not going to try and trade in and
out of
price adjustments i'm going to allocate
three percent and if the price drops
i'll buy
more that's the whole point and that's
what i've done and the whole idea at the
end of the day here is
to keep that three percent allocation
now if i increase it up to five i'll
have to buy more
but that's a discipline of just
portfolio management but the
the actual asset bitcoin itself to me is
a property
it it's something you own its value
increases over time
due to scarcity and complexity of mining
and being awarded
a coin all of these things factor into
it now
the truth is the institutional investor
is not on board yet but my thesis is
when we resolve the issues around
bitcoin right now in the next couple of
years
and allocations start happening from
sovereign funds and pension plans
you're going to see a material
appreciation in price
i mean i think we we agree with you
strongly on that one um
but when you talk about property right
property needs to be
easy to transfer between people right i
would say if you compare
you just discussed watches right but you
could also discuss
you know maybe urban land buildings
stuff like that that are historically
used as store values
um would you say that with bitcoin
there's an advantage that it's more
liquid even if you're not necessarily
planning on transferring it to another
person do not expect
that there will be a healthy p2p
transfer you know economy
a market for it yeah i think it's great
that it's so
you know fungible in the fact that it's
easy to transfer i mean that's built
into the
you know the whole metric of what
bitcoin is i mean you it goes really
back to the binary decision do i own it
or not but
you know everybody has an opinion about
what it is some some people
do not own it because they don't believe
in it i don't see any reason why
digital assets won't appreciate in value
like every other kind of asset frankly
to me this is an asset class and you
have to make a decision on what you own
how you own it
and what you want to call it i mean the
most desirable asset in crypto
is bitcoin it is the gold standard of
crypto
and basically institutions that are just
stepping in or considering getting
involved in allocating to crypto
want one thing bitcoin now they have to
own it
sustainably mined as you know that's
become an issue over the last few months
they also have some ethics committees
that are involved in making decisions
about asset classes not just bitcoin any
any asset
and so we need to resolve these issues
around the bitcoin dialogue
and the reason i'm involved in that is
that i want the coin to appreciate and i
know the way to get it to appreciate the
fastest
is to get institutional allocation how
do i get that
i solve the esg problem i say i solve it
i mean collectively we've got to solve
it
they'll start buying it when they can go
to the compliance committees and say
this is ethically mined and it's
sustainably mined
and a story what would you say to
someone who says
um the scarcity of bitcoin cannot be
preserved
that that someone somewhere will print
bitcoin in the future what
what makes you think that that won't
happen the baseline algorithm for how
bitcoin is
is awarded is well known i mean it's
it's not a secret
uh if you're asking me is it going to
get hacked
my answer is no and i think the whole
point of the chain is to identify
you know these coins when they were
actually awarded
is a pretty solid structure and over
time more and more people
will agree that that is what gives them
the confidence
to own this property and you know i'd
argue it's the same as
any other asset you know you talk about
diamonds for example the the attempts to
to identify diamonds one way or another
or from you know mine one certain way
versus another way
the diamond market's still very fungible
you basically weigh the carrots you look
at the quality of it
um you determine what the price is we
don't have that issue
around bitcoin it's awarded you know the
date it was awarded
and so far the value of each coin
regardless of where it was mined is
trading in tandem
the price is the price wherever it is
now you can you may pay a lot of fees to
trade your coin it depends what
you know what platform you're using but
there are institutional platforms
emerging that are compliant now that are
preparing for the day when
a pension plan says i'm putting a three
or five percent allocation a sovereign
fund might
that's billions of dollars they will not
do that if they think there's a way
to basically fraud people out of bitcoin
that's not going to happen i don't think
so and i'm confident i'm not worried
about it
there are those out there that say
that's possible i don't i don't believe
that
so i guess i mean very insightful answer
but to be a little bit more pointed here
um from my viewpoint on bitcoin
the scarcity is preserved because it's a
distributed system because it's a system
that's not controlled by anybody
right and we've seen with centralized
systems that they have a tendency to
to inflate their supply be greedy try
and control things right
um at the same time we have this
competing interest that we want to see
you know more regulatory compliance more
uh
adoption within institutional circles
um do you view that as a bit of an
existential threat that if if
bitcoin gets too centralized or too
controlled by a small group of people
that that scarcity that value prop
is at risk it's a great discussion it
certainly
was at the fore of what was happening at
bitcoin 2021 that discussion was ongoing
every day
and and it is a concern but generally
speaking when you think about bitcoin
um i don't see a situation where it's
going to be made illegal anywhere
and the thesis is you know genie's out
of the bottle
bitcoin is distributed all around the
world and used as property and currency
in
every country on earth and so i don't
really see
even if one country says they're going
to make it illegal how they're exactly
going to do that
and so i think regulators would prefer
to work with the fact
that this property in my case
property is here to stay and they're
going to have to deal with it now i
don't have a problem if uh in any
jurisdiction they say look if you gain
capital gains on the sale of your
bitcoin you owe taxes
i own that on any asset i'm okay with
that but regulating it out of existence
is a low probability as far as i'm
concerned not going to happen in fact
it's going the other way
you know let's just take a pragmatic
approach looking at a two trillion
dollar infrastructure package
we're not going to print two trillion
dollars worth of paper
by the time that program is actually
implemented it's going to be some form
of
digital currency whether it's just you
know usd
stablecoin or whatever it is or just
credits done electronically to
governments at the state level or even
contractors that currency is going to be
digital
it's just in what form and so the
world's going to move towards digital
currency
bitcoin was the beginning of that it is
the granddaddy of it all which is why
it's so desirable
it's the fb journey watch i talked of
earlier if if i only could own
one digital asset it would be bitcoin
but i'm planning to own a lot more
in a portfolio approach but because it
was the first
it's always going to have that unique
position
being the first is always the first and
i don't think that
governments are going to say
collectively in sync
let's ban all digital currency ain't
going to happen
all right so a few minutes ago you
mentioned
that you think bs or that btc needs to
head
to the esg realm what is your vision
for uh getting bitcoin uh compliant with
these
sort of regulatory i mean you're viewing
them essentially as
roadblocks if i understand you correctly
you're saying that we make bitcoin
esg and that unlocks all this
institutional adoption
investment what does esg bitcoin look
like to you
well i'm very involved in that um and
and i've had many discussions with
you know some of the some of the larger
uh players in bitcoin
in terms of ownership and assets and the
reason we have a collective interest in
it is that we see
the log jam being broken up and then
institutions coming into an asset class
we already are positioned in that's a
very
attractive outcome and so here's what i
think
originally the discussions were around
the idea of tagging the coin
in other words this coin was mined
sustainably with hydro this coin was
mine sustained with wind or solar
these coins were made in a way that
there is no issue around
burning coal and it was made you know
perhaps in west texas or whatever
but it's tagged that way and the problem
with that thought
is that all of a sudden you
differentiate two classes of bitcoin
they're not fungible anymore and the
thesis was that maybe the green one
trades at a premium
i don't like that idea because i'd like
to know that any bitcoin trades in
tandem with any bitcoin price and those
prices are on a discovery basis
24 hours a day every minute here's a
better outcome
for institutions that do not own
own coin yet uh that are thinking of
allocating
here's one solution there are certain
miners out there
um take hud 8 for example
that owned every coin they ever mined on
their balance sheet and it was mined
sustainably
you can just buy their stock and own
that balance sheet that's one solution
and no with certainty the coin that you
own through the equity ownership
is esg sustainable and your compliance
committee could check the box on that
but i think what really is going to
happen with the 2.3 whatever it is
remaining coins to be 9 million
let's say you set up a new miner and
just do it again in west texas
which right now looks very attractive
government's on board state level
you've also got lots of wind and lots of
solar you've got all kinds of extra
energy there that you could use on a
sustainable basis so you set up a mine
facility there
and i'm an institution that only wants
to know the providence of my coin
i simply fund that development i put the
capex into that and i take my payback
in coin that i own put on my balance
sheet in perpetuity just like a building
in new york city
i bought that property i own that
property i know where it came from
i know with a hundred percent certainty
that it's esg compliant
and it's on my balance sheet that is i
think where we're going you've heard
all of the discussions in the last few
weeks about
every miner moving towards
sustainability figuring that out because
the institutional buyer
is asking for that at a very minimum and
i think that that development of that
idea is really strong because it doesn't
differentiate one coin from another
it just makes the next 2.4 million the
majority of them will be mined
sustainably
first of all that answer makes a lot of
sense i mean we were definitely
interested in your thoughts on you know
based on your prior tweets you know are
these going to trade at different values
uh a lot of people have compared
investing in bitcoin to the gold rush
right you have the people that mined
gold and made money doing that
you also had people who made money uh
selling jeans and work boots and
pickaxes and i know you're you're a vc
you know your your shark tank obviously
you've got this three percent portfolio
exposure to bitcoin
are you invested directly in any
companies in the bitcoin space
specifically with bitcoin yes
i have started to allocate capital it's
a very good question because
the infrastructure required for bitcoin
and all dungeon current
digital currencies is going to be
decentralized and so
i recently uh took a large equity
position in a startup
that was called d5 ventures and i
renamed it wonderful
sort of a rip-off of richard branson
if he can pull that off with virgin i
can't i don't understand why i can't do
it with wonderful
because that business is about you know
making it easy for consumers
to own bitcoin and be able to monetize
bitcoin with smart contracts so they can
get yield
and so it has to be tax compliant it has
to be easy to use and so we're designing
that that's
one of my one of my investments i also
have two others pending
that are more institutional in nature
that provide platforms for
the world i work in i work i do a lot of
work with pension plans and sovereign
plans
in the indexing world and in that space
um
they need compliant platforms so if they
want to invo
invest in stable coin or bitcoin or a
combination of both or write smart
contracts
they do it on a compliance platform that
actually fits with their institutional
compliance departments
and those are two different ways to look
at it and again that as you suggest is
infrastructure
and it really goes in supporting you
know
what i do on a portfolio basis i'm
probably going to bring my waiting up
i'm not announcing this today i'm just
saying i'm looking at
um increasing my allocation next stop
will be five percent on bitcoin
and in at the same time investing in
infrastructure
uh so that i can actually do the same
thing that anybody else wants to
i would like to actually make yield off
my coin and that involves
in getting a platform that allows me to
do that
easily compliantly with tax reporting i
need tax reporting i have to be
compliant
you're hearing the same words coming out
of me that every institution has
and we haven't really built those
platforms yet which is why i'm investing
in some of the ones that are starting up
this is part of what it's going to take
it's not just on to get people on board
to buy bitcoin because we've solved the
esg problem it's then
how do you manage your portfolio how do
you
use it to create fiat in other words you
can
you know go to get a stable coin on
almost an interest rate basis through a
smart contract and then convert that
back to fiat
if you want a distribution so there's a
lot going on back there
in financial infrastructure and that's
the world i live in and i'm extremely
interested so
i am investing more capital um i
i bet you and i'm just thinking about
today alone how many meetings i've had
this morning
on exactly these topics i'm spending 80
percent of my day
that i allocate to investment portfolio
on on bitcoin and crypto
bitcoin has a way of doing that it tends
to consume all your
thought processes once you start getting
in for me and david
you know we've you know been in bitcoin
a little bit longer than you maybe
um we look at like a five percent
allocation you know
it's like what is this an allocation for
ants right and we hear
we hear yield and the chase for yield
and i me personally i think that's a
distraction right and i
i i think that bitcoin is the type of
asset that has major upside potential
is super scarce going through an
adoption phase
um the returns have been absolutely
insane year over year
is there a number that you're looking
for in terms of
like making that risk worth you know
risking your coins to get to get that
kind of yield is there
is there a specific threshold you're
looking at
there's many different strategies and
the problem with all of them is i had to
hire two people just to implement them
it's so complex
the average person isn't going to go
through that and so we need to make that
an option if you wish
it's not that risky it what it what you
need essentially is volatility and
bitcoin gives you volatility
the more volatility on bitcoin the more
yields you can make
so you know i i look at it this way
somebody asked me the other day
okay if you bought bitcoin at uh you
know
40 000 and now it's or you know 55 000
and now it's dropped down to 40 000 does
that bother you i said no it doesn't
because i've made the decision
to call it property it's like a building
i own in boston
the price of of real estate goes up and
down through market cycles but i still
own the building
and i feel the same way about bitcoin i
kind of agnostic
to volatility on its price hour by hour
don't really care but the gift that
keeps on giving with volatility
is i know how to get yield out of it now
and so i think more
investors are going to follow my path on
this the great thing about
bitcoin is it gives you lots of
optionality there's
many things you can do with it if you
wish to and you may decide as i have
that it's property and i want to mine
the value out of that property
no different than when i own a building
or hotel in boston
i want to get monthly distributions
because i rent the rooms out i rent the
office space
i can do the same thing with bitcoin i
got no problem with that
so earlier you sort of said going back
to the clean energy
bitcoin conversation your answer is
basically look if you want clean bitcoin
mine bitcoin cleanly invest in the tech
go out to west texas do it here in the
united states
uh and and get the bitcoin you know is
cleanly mined but
we've also heard the argument tossed
around and i'm definitely partial to it
that bitcoin itself incentivizes more
efficient
uh energy uses that bitcoin incentivizes
renewable energy
uh you know if you uh you know realize
that the difficulty of mining bitcoin is
going to just keep increasing every four
years
some people think we're gonna reach a
point where the only way you could even
possibly mine the stuff is
is with renewables so do you buy into
that argument that bitcoin incentivizes
investment in green tech incentivizes
investment in renewables
i do actually i'd go a step further i
would say
because of the complexity you're talking
about for the next two and a half
million
coins it's going to advance
semiconductor technology as well
you're going to need to be able to get
renewable power no question about it
you know at two or three cents and
you're going to need a significant
enhancement
on the chipsets and the machinery it's
going to take to actually process
the awards going forward it just gets
harder and harder so
that's got lots of people working on new
technologies to do this
and i think that advances a lot of
different things number one it advances
clean power new technologies in solar
and wind certainly end in hydro but at
the same time
you know whatever machine you're mining
with right now has got to get 20
more efficient in the next two years and
that's going to be
the purvey of american providers i think
they'll be coming out
most of this stuff is made in china we
got to end that we have to take lead
here if the chinese are starting to shut
down their miners or at least putting
more pressure on them
why not pick up the slack in the pools
here in the us let's make
this country the number one miner of
sustainable coin
ethically mined coin coin mined with
sustainable power
that matches every esg concern there's
another
80 years of work to do so it's not going
away anytime soon
and we can lead the charge now not
everybody agrees that bitcoin
is like the new gold you know gold's
been around since the romans that's why
i have a five percent waiting in that
and that was mine back in on the island
of cyprus 2000 years ago so there
weren't really a lot of sustainability
esg issues back then
that same gold is sitting on the planet
right now and that's the argument you
know people say it must be very very
polluting to mine gold and not esg at
all
and they're right but the majority of
the gold that's sitting on the planet
right now is mine before there are any
esg tests at all
so that's the way you look at that for
the remainder of bitcoin
this is going to be done sustainably
there's no question
it's not what i want or you want it's
what the institutions want
and in order for to get price
appreciation
in order to get bitcoin to beat the
stock indexes we're going to need the
institutions we just
there's no other question it has to
happen that way which is why you hear
every minor and you certainly heard them
talk
i mean i i paneled the i moderated the
panel for public minors
as you know at bitcoin 2021 every single
one of them whether it's fred at
marathon or
anybody else there was talking about how
they're shifting their whole focus
towards sustainability on the energy
source
frank holmes same way at hive all of
them same message
so when you're speaking to these
institutions in some ways
you are uh you know an advocate of
bitcoin you know you've been in the
space you've clearly done your homework
and have learned a lot about the
ecosystem
what is your general message to
institutions that are
curious about when someone calls you and
they say kevin what is bitcoin
why should i invest you know what is
your message to institutional investors
that are still on the fence
i say to them look because they they
obviously see i'm out there talking
about the three percent allocation
saying how did you do it
what methodology are you using how
you're getting around the esg issue
that's how i actually got contacted the
first time i disclosed i had three
percent it was the institutions i worked
for in the indexing business that called
me
and that's when the dialogue started so
the majority uh have not yet
um got involved in bitcoin you heard the
same out of larry think a few weeks ago
when he talked about the global
asset allocation business he manages
that he's not getting a lot of demand
and it's partly because of the letter he
keeps putting out about sustainability
climate change and everything else that
every asset not just bitcoin
every single asset should be tested for
by your esg committee to make sure that
is
it is being created on a sustainable
basis and so my message is
is that the industry itself the the
bitcoin mining community the global
community the majority of miners
certainly all the miners in the u.s have
pivoted in the last six months
towards a sustainability model we saw
this first happen with new york bill
which is still going through its
iterations
saying that they will ban all bitcoin
money except if you can prove that you
are mining bitcoin
with 100 sustainable energy so
that's going to be the rule of new york
texas is a is a much more friendly
government
and they also have a very good
environment for sustainable energy
sources particularly solar and wind
in the end of the day when i say the
institution is look i can show you a
path
to how you can own a coin that you know
the providence of
you just simply invest in a miner that's
mining 100 of their coin and being
awarded coins that are mined
sustainably and you'll own it and slowly
that thought process is starting to to
go into the
investment allocation committees but we
have not broken the log jam yet we're
nowhere near it
there's more work to be done one of the
coolest parts about bitcoin mining to me
is that it's it's this quest for cheap
energy one of the the main costs of
mining
is your energy cost um and to me it's
it's it's a permissionless system where
anyone can plug in
uh it's one of the truest free markets
that that the world has ever seen this
competition among miners looking for
cheap energy
um on the esg side i mean this is a
compliance hurdle that
that that large corporate miners are
going to be doing
um that seems like it would undoubtedly
increase cost do you expect
that there's going to be two tiers of
miners there's going to be like smaller
miners that are more distributed
seeking out cheap energy and then
there's a larger more compliant miners
that may be paying a higher cost
net out you can be
a miner burning cold great electricity
and be very profitable
but you will never get an institutional
following if you if you really want to
expand and raise capex to build out
more facilities no one's going to
support you
unless you can do it on your own income
if you have enough take all your profits
convert it back to fiat
build out you know facilities and in
wherever you're going to build them
that's fine
right now every single public miner is
telling the
esg story and showing how they can do it
and in some cases buying carbon credits
not because they want to these are all
added costs as you suggested
they have no alternative there's no
other option they have to be esg
sustainable and they have to be
compliant with their esg committees
and that's the bottom line but you know
going when you start thinking about
access to capital there is capital
available for those miners that have a
path to doing 100 renewable energy
sources
and the returns look really good i mean
you know bitcoin is volatile there's no
question about it
but i think every day we move towards
more adoption at the institutional level
but there's going to be the tipping
point the proverbial tipping point when
all of a sudden one or two or three
large institutions do an allocation
and you're going to see the price of
bitcoin skyrocket
you talked about texas uh being this
sort of especially west texas all the
winning
wind energy being a great place in
america to go mine bitcoin
uh you know they changed their law they
uh updated the uniform commercial code
to provide regulatory clarity and uh
just sort of i guess financial clarity
around
how bitcoin works uh i think it had to
do with
the ability to loan bitcoin and some
confusion there
do you think we're going to see that
trend across the state i mean because
right now
uh if you wanted to build a bitcoin
business there's a good chance you'd go
to texas
uh and if they start to see all this
investment all these companies move
there do you think that might trigger a
domino effect do you think other states
could be poised to follow texas to try
to capture some of that new investment
i wouldn't say every state it's going to
be state by state i'll give you an
example i think new york's a very poorly
managed state i think massachusetts is
poorly managed i think california is
poorly managed
and the way you can tell is just look at
their tax rates
the lifestyle there is no better or
worse than here where i am in florida or
texas and yet you pay
a stratospherically higher tax rate so
they're just poorly managed
they make bad decisions like the one
they're making right now but bitcoin
mining in new york
uh they're not they're just poorly
managed and and so i i wouldn't invest
i don't invest in businesses in those
states because they're not competitive i
invest in businesses in texas
and in florida because they're
competitive and they have a very
pro-business you know smear suarez here
in miami he's very pro-business he's
pro-bitcoin
uh he's pro-digital and so i prefer to
do business here
i i can make that choice as an investor
every day and i do and so i think we're
going to end up with states like texas
for bitcoin which has clearly made it a
state mandate
they need to attract those jobs attract
that technology
and attract that desire for clean energy
all to their state at the same time
and many representatives from texas were
at bitcoin 2021 i met with
everybody there backstage it was the
discussion about
they were smart enough to bring
representatives to the conference not
knowing
what would happen at that conference
because nobody expected what occurred
there
you know if we're going to talk about
the conference for a moment i tell you
why i consider it important
to me that was a pivotal moment in the
history of bitcoin it was it was a
moment
on the second day when it was clear that
something was
happening not only um you know did they
get the numbers wrong or i should say
you guys got the numbers wrong but it's
to your upside
the the place was like woodstock it had
gone from being a
niche tiny little vertical
to mainstream mainstream press
mainstream politicians mainstream
investors institutional investors
mainstream everything for those three
days
and the number of meetings i had and the
dialogue that occurred and then the
international press
i mean it was it was a game changer and
it will go down in my view in the years
ahead as the moment
the change occurred when bitcoin went
mainstream
and you looked like you were having a
blast i mean when i saw you you looked
like you were having fun
yeah i was because some very heavy duty
watch collectors were there
paying in bitcoin paying in bitcoin for
their watches it was pretty cool
what a what a mister wonderful moment
there bitcoin and watches being
transferred at the 2021 conference will
you be here at the 2022 conference
oh no question i i just i think um
it was well organized it had the right
topic matter
the people that put that together in the
discussions we had prior to the
different panels um i mean you know
public capital
is the world i live in so we always have
to watch where institutional money is
so the next conference we're going to
take it we want to take an index of what
what's changed in 12 months what did we
achieve on the success scale and what
did we lose on the failure scale in
terms of getting
more institutional capital into the
asset class that will be
certainly a panel i will want to
moderate when we look at it because by
then there should be at least
a doubling in the number of public
miners and we'll have a much bigger
contingency to talk to
and get some indication of how far we've
gone towards getting
mainstream with institutions in terms of
their ownership of bitcoin
if you like that video where did you see
my next one
don't forget to click right over here
and subscribe